[Musica]
era il 1998 e in questa foto avevo 24
anni e mi hanno regalato un bellissimo
regalo bellissimo viaggio ai caraibi a
cuba e senza saperlo
in questo in questo viaggio da qui in
avanti la mia la mia vita è
completamente cambiata
[Musica]
stavo ricevendo il mio battesimo in
barca a vela
ero a bordo di questo bellissimo
catamarano molto molto grande
ricordo perfettamente è ancora oggi nel
momento in cui mi sedetti a prua di uno
dei due scafi andavo incontro a queste
onde oceaniche alte come palazzi di
cinque sei piani e ricordo ancora che
che abbassando lo sguardo vedevo il pelo
d'acqua che che veniva verso di me e
sfiorava la punta dei piedi e il momento
dopo invece questo tendeva ad
allontanarsi sempre di più e nel momento
in cui c'era questo movimento di
avvicinamento e di allontanamento e il
respiro sentivo che che prendeva la
stessa velocità allo stesso moto e lì ho
capito che stava entrando in piena
totale sintonia con quello che era il
mare in questo caso l'oceano
dovete pensare che io fino a una
manciata fino alla manciata di giorni
prima di questo momento ero meglio mi
definivo un montanaro una persona che
amava di più gli sport legati alla
montagna come l'andare a sciare andare a
passeggiare ma banalmente anche il giro
in moto domenicale non ero molto
attratto dal mare anche se io sono
fortemente legato alle mie origini
in realtà su nato e cresciuto diciamo
così con un sentimento quasi restio ecco
verso il mare perché diciamo detta fra
di noi e l'alto adriatico non è che a
questi grandi colori e invece l'oceano
mia mi ha risvegliato un sentimento
molto profondo per il mare e in quel
caso l'oceano come tutti quanti bei
viaggi però anche questo arrivò presto
alla sua conclusione
e ricordo benissimo che ancora prima di
sbarcare a malpensa dentro di me avevo
questo tarlo fisso ed ero già convinto
nonostante fosse conscio di non avere
nessuna nozione sulla navigazione ero
già convinto di voler tornare i caraibi
di tornarci attraversando l'atlantico in
barca a vela e non chiedetemi perché io
ero già straconvinto che sarei tornato
quel giorno in solitaria torna a casa
questo questo pensiero dentro la mia
testa continua a rimanere fisso
poche settimane più tardi ricordo di
avere acquistato questa la moto dei miei
sogni quella che io veramente sognavo da
una vita
pensate che mi piaceva così tanto che
quando tornava a casa alla sera nel
parcheggiare in garage
rimanevo diversi minuti a a guardarla
contemplarla e quindi aveva un doppio
godimento 1 ne starci sopra quando
giravo per strada e e l'altro invece
quando tornava a casa alla sera che la
riponeva in garage
mancava soltanto che gli mettessi un
lenzuolo una copertina sopra e che le
desse una carezza prima di andare a
dormire poi tutto un tratto arriva un
flash veramente spettacolare e subito
dopo mi risveglio e in una stanza
d'ospedale in un ambiente veramente
stranissimo con persone che urlavano il
buio ricordo veramente delle cose molto
molto scioccanti iniziare a muovere un
po le braccia che sentivo che avevo
diverse difficoltà mi stavo guardando e
vedevo tubi filati ovunque
ciononostante non mi sono lasciato
prendere dalla crisi da dalla paura dal
terrore di quello che di quello che mi
fosse successo
avevo già intuito che che fosse successo
qualcosa di molto grave
però poi come siamo fattori di carattere
vedi insomma passare la prima infermiera
questo è stato veramente una cosa anche
un po comica se vogliamo yo yo con po
d'imbarazzo fermai questi infermiere le
chiesi scusi per queste cose quanto si
di man si rimane in ospedale perché
avrei parcheggiate umani furgoni in
ditte non vorrei che i titolari fossero
arrabbiati
mentre questi palazzi erano fuori dalla
porta che stavano piangendo per quello
che mi era successo
ecco questo per farvi capire che tipo di
carattere io abbia io di fronte alle
difficoltà ho sempre reagito in maniera
normale cioè per me la vita continua
si va avanti giorno per giorno ho fatto
una degenza ospedaliera che è durata
appena quattro mesi nonostante insomma
la lesione particolarmente molto grave e
farà ridere probabilmente a molti di voi
ma tornai a casa addirittura con la
fidanzata nuova e questo per dirvi
insomma il carattere la forza
probabilmente grazie anche gli
insegnamenti come sono stato cresciuto
no se volevo qualcosa mi è stato
insegnato che dovevo tenerlo con le mie
forze e non contare mais nessuno ecco
questo probabilmente in questo momento
brutto della mia vita mi ha dato
l'energia per superare il tutto poche
settimane poche settimane più tardi da
questo da questa sono stato dimesso
dall'ospedale si torna a casa
cerco di riprendere la mia vita
torno a lavorare nonostante i pareri
contrari dei medici e delle persone che
mi circondavano
però io volevo riprendere la mia vita in
mano dopo di nuovo e andare avanti
da lì e chiedo alla mia ragazza di
accompagnarmi volevo tornare al mare
rimettere i piedi in acqua ed è stato un
momento molto molto divertente anche
questo perché eravamo a sottomarina
dovete immaginare una persona dimessa da
poco quindi con una mobilità molto molto
inferiore a quella che oggi oggi sono
abbastanza energico nonostante l'età si
faccia acquisire la certo a mola arrivai
in questa spiaggia due amici mi presero
il braccio mie mi misero a sedere sopra
una bellissima moto d'acqua 1800 4 tempi
nella moto veramente potentissima e
cinque minuti più tardi nonostante tutte
le raccomandazioni e marco vai piano
marco mi raccomando marco stai attento
dieci minuti dopo avete visto vedevate
questa persona anche che sfrecciava
davanti alla battigia a velocità assurde
intorno ai cento all'ora e contento come
una pasqua che per che tornavo da una
parte in mare e dall'altra a dare gas a
un mezzo molto potente e quindi per me
era veramente tornare tornare di nuovo a
vivere torna però il mio pensiero a
quale sport tornare a fare e mi viene di
nuovo in mente la navigazione in questo
mio sogno nel cassetto che che volevo
assolutamente conquistare prima di avere
questo incidente
mi misi a cercare la scuola vela adatta
a me io volevo diventare un navigatore
non un velista non mi accontentavo della
piccola deriva io volevo stare a bordo
di una grande barca perché il mio sogno
poi era quello di attraversare
l'atlantico trovai questa scuola
sabaudia dove mi diedero veramente delle
grandi opportunità equipara diventare un
navigatore
il mio sogno era proprio quello di fare
il navigatore non il velista a me
piaceva l'idea di mollare gli ormeggi di
e di partire di andare non di fare
regate in brevi specchi d'acqua e
durante questo percorso durato circa
quindici anni ho avuto l'opportunità
anche di insegnare a mia volta da
l'arte della vela di avvicinarli alla
marineria e a tutte queste a questo
bellissimo sport fino all'età dei 40
anni ha 40 anni e ho sentito dentro di
me questa la consapevolezza di aver
accumulato una discreta esperienza e
dall'altra parte mi sentivo come di
essere arrivato a un giro di boa e ha
cominciato dentro di me è una una voce
che dava a fare o adesso o mai più
o adesso o mai più dovete pensare che
con la disabilità devi devi pensare deve
prevedere quello che sarà un po il tuo
futuro non puoi pensare di arrivare a 70
anni e 60 come tutti gli altri
quindi io ho visto i miei 40 anni come
un come il tempo limite per riaprire
questo sogno questo mio cassetto dove
all'interno c'è questo bellissimo storia
di attraversare l'atlantico
da lì allora ho deciso di prendere una
pausa da questi insegnamenti della vela
e ho deciso di mettere di iniziare a
costruirmi il mio programma il mio
percorso mio il mio programma di
atlantico
chiamiamolo così e ho pensato come per
come sono fatto io di partire a a
piccoli step quindi ho immaginato prima
di tutto di iniziare a fare un qualcosa
di forte che mi desse capire anche cosa
significa stare in mare da solo a
gestire una barca di piccole dimensioni
cercando di fare una navigazione di
tutto sommato anche in sicurezza lungo
costa monitorato perché serviva da
tester e anche perché sapevo che questa
navigazione era talmente se sarebbe
stata così tanto seguita che è creare un
problema avrei creato anche un
precedente molto importante per tutto
quello che è il mondo della disabilità
quindi carico di questa responsabilità
ho pensato di fare una cosa più più
tranquilla possibile anche se lo diranno
in molti un giro d'italia esattamente
non lo fa proprio chiunque ci sono quei
4 5 punti di mare italiano dove si trovi
il meteo in condizioni avverse uscirne
diventa veramente una grande impresa
scopro che il giro d'italia non l'aveva
mai fatto nessun disabile prima di me o
meglio non l'aveva mai fatto
un disabile con la paraplegia quindi una
persona dove deve gestire con un terzo
del proprio fisico tutto tutto quanto il
corpo intero
io non ho l'uso degli addominali da dal
petto in giù non hanno sensibilità e non
o mobilità quindi non è non è che si
trattasse solo di gestire una barca ma
si trattava di gestire anche anche me
stesso non avendo più 20 anni avendo
anche messo su qualche chiletto diciamo
che la difficoltà era anche un po
aumentata
però non mi sono perso di coraggio a ero
conscio delle mie capacità e decisi di
intraprendere questo bellissimo viaggio
in questo viaggio
io dico sempre che in solitaria ma in
realtà in solitaria non c'era perché ero
accompagnato dal mio fedele compagno a
quattro zampe e matri in questa
bellissima foto come lo vedete ogni
volta che arrivavamo vicino al porto
d'arrivo della della tappa si metteva in
quella posizione guardava avanti
probabilmente perché non vedeva l'ora di
scendere per andare a fare i suoi
bisogni per mangiare per scorrazzare un
pochettino
l'idea era probabilmente questo annusare
l'arrivo della tappa che anche quella
giornata finalmente era volta al termine
c'è una bellissima foto della partenza
da venezia e del trimarano e matri siamo
partiti veramente a cannone come si suol
dire in questa foto scattata da una
barca d'appoggio che mi stava seguendo
per poche migliaia gli stavo giocando
letteralmente al gatto e al topo quindi
è stata una giornata veramente molto
emozionante la partenza veramente a
missile ero carichissimo è pronto a
percorrere queste 1.700 miglia circa
lungo costa e per sei mesi di durata
pensate che in questa imbarcazione sono
passato dal vivere da una casa di
campagna con tutti gli spazi che potete
immaginare a circa tre metri quadrati
appena dove ho condiviso il mio spazio
insieme a matri all'interno vi aveva un
letto ce l'aveva lui un l'ex l'avevo io
avevamo il bagno i cugini non si mancava
nulla ma tutto era diventato un
microcosmo di appena tre metri quadrati
una cosa che che ricorderemo per tutta
quanta la vita soprattutto in momenti
più brutti che ci siamo trovati a
doverci sbrigare tra ravenna tra l'altro
gargano insomma li sono stati momenti
più più duri ma li abbiamo superati
siamo arrivati presto alla fine e nella
prossima immagine vedrete anche l'ultimo
pallino che ci siamo smezzato e
passatemi il termine io e marley con una
buona bottiglia di prosecco eravamo
arrivati a qui erano bellissime immagini
davanti a portofino
ci mancavano veramente le ultime emilia
circa 10 20 miglia per arrivare a genova
e finire così nostro primo lungo grande
viaggio arriviamo alla fine di questo
giro d'italia io comincio a pensare
seriamente al all'atlantico comincia a
pensare alla navigazione che mi
aspetterà anche già da quest'anno mi sto
preparando a delle cose sempre alzando
un po l'asticella e quindi cercando di
portare sempre più i miei limiti
oltre io in tutta questa cosa qui sto
sto cercando di prendere il 2024 è un po
la tappa che io mi sono prefisso per
fare questa traversata atlantica nel
nel novembre del 2000 e 24 novembre
perché perché la traversata
dell'atlantico e di normalmente si fanno
sfruttando gli alisei le correnti marine
e in quell'anno in quel mese io compirò
50 anni
voglio assolutamente regalarmi questo
bellissimo compleanno e chiudere un po
il cerchio facendo fede un po a una mia
vecchia promessa e prendere i miei
limiti e farne letteralmente i
coriandoli voglio essere sicuramente da
una parte il primo navigatore
paraplegico ad aver traversato
l'atlantico
e arrivare in fondo e aspettare la
quelle che saranno le classiche domande
e in questo contesto
se mi chiedete che cosa sarà per me
andare oltre ogni limite
io vi risponderò né più né meno che per
me semplicemente continuare a vivere